[Applause]
that is so true i wouldn't lie i
wouldn't lie
well happy magical friday everyone neil
cavuto is off tonight and i'm pete
hegsith
hi kid i'm so much better looking
but what a great show we have for you
it's almost so good i almost don't want
to share it with you but i will because
i'm a giving person
just ask the nurses at the blood bank
sometimes i'll even donate my own
now there's been a lot of talk about who
the democratic nominee should be for
2024 we aren't even halfway through this
term and they already want to bail on
joe it's the only bail democrats support
[Music]
but
but can you blame them his favorability
rating is two points ahead of rheumatoid
arthritis and three points below anal
warts
seems like that should be reversed but
anyway but that doesn't seem fair to joe
at all he's got the experience he's got
the look you could say he has the human
touch right ask any 15 year old girl
whose shoulders he rubbed like he's a
prize fighter or had her hair sniffed
like he's huffing pantene pro-v
but instead you see dem circling him
like seagulls above a fishing boat ready
to pounce on anything the crew throws
overboard
gavin newsom just visited dc he brought
a tape measure
not for the white house drapes but a
coffin
for joe
gavin always masks up when he visits
joe's office he takes it off once he's
sure that there isn't a dead body in
there
so disgusting
but like my wife and that homeless
musician she invited to live in our
addict
they aren't even hiding it anymore
they're like your worst relatives who
know you're rich and have a weak heart
and suddenly they're mailing you boxes
of omaha steaks cases of red bull and
keep sneaking up behind you at family
functions with an air horn
but here at gutfeld we say no
like brian kilmeade's breath the biden
name is too strong to ignore
oh so now you're on his side
which is why i'm saying it's time to
support biden 2024.
that's right biden 2024
roll the nexio
[Music]
[Applause]
that's right forget joe it's time for
hunter
after all joe says hunter is the
smartest guy he knows so it stands to
reason he'll be an improvement
you think i'm kidding but hear me out
there's a ton of reasons why hunter
would make a great president first of
all unlike most politicians hunter can't
be blackmailed
seriously
seriously
what if some foreign agent approaches
him and says mr president we have video
of you masturbating
hunter would probably reply
fine
but do you have one from this angle
or this angle how about this i can get
you high def if you like
of course most presidents have first
ladies and they always have some crusade
that keeps them busy and it never works
remember how michelle obama tackled
childhood obesity
i didn't think kids could get any fatter
but hunter you know instead of instead
of a first lady
he'll have first ladies
of the evening
how fun would it be to see him slow
dancing at the inauguration with an
eastern european in pumps short shorts
and a belly shirt
while eight more dressed similarly are
lounging in the grotto that used to be
the lincoln bedroom
the and even better the guy knows
business
if anyone can this guy could pay off the
national debt hell his paintings are
worth a half mil a pop he could pump out
400 of those a month right out of his
nose
he also knows creative accounting as
well prostitutes as a medical service i
mean i need to switch doctors
although his advisors are going to want
to be very specific with hunter when
they bring up inflation
but
he can also tackle the drug crisis who
better to deal with drug cartels than
someone who has their direct number
and remember did you see him
thoughtfully weighing the crack in front
of the hooker
no i just laid out the bag
it's
2.06 two point
zero seven
without the bag
so how long is that
2.0
hundred's the only guy that does drugs
wearing a gopro
but
[Laughter]
you saw how precise he was finally
here's a politician interested in
lowering all drug prices
plus you want transparency this guy is
naked 100 of the time
hunter has his clothes off so much that
when he wants to go swimming he has to
add clothes
[Laughter]
and what's the most important question
for a president will you be awake at 3am
to take the phone call
[Laughter]
yeah you can bet hunter will be awake
at 3am to take any call
unless it's from a baby mama
but in any emergency hunter will always
be the first one there because he won't
waste time getting dressed
so yeah the wrong biden is running joe
was right hunter's a genius the guy took
his family name and turned it into a
cash cow that fueled unadulterated
reckless hedonism most crack addicts
would be incarcerated but this guy he's
in malibu he must have don jr thinking
why the hell didn't i do that
so there you have it hunter should run
and i think he's got the balls to do it
because i've seen them in the video
they made they may want to have them
looked at though they're a little
they're a little blurry
what do you think joe
ah give me a break man get the facts
jack
i'm driving this thing all right
hunter's behind me that's where it
always works we're a team
we're like a mullet business in the
front party in the back
so we're all in agreement here keep it
in the family hunter biden 2024 the
slogan could be the biden you can trust
to make it to the top of the stairs
just keep them away from your daughters
and your medicine cabinet
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's yes
he's so brilliant all of his teeth our
wisdom teeth
novelist and literary critic walter kerr
and
uh an old friend she knows human rights
like i know fishnet tights human rights
lawyer and award-winning filmmaker and
author brook goldstein
[Applause]
she has the gift of gab and is known to
stab fox news contributor cat time
the last time he butted heads was at
mount rushmore
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
walter
isn't this a great idea shouldn't we get
behind hunter 100
better than being in front of him
well
you know since you stole the joke i told
you at dinner last night about the 3 a.m
phone call
stole it you gave it to me oh you're
right you're right
like i have any choice
i bought you a crab cake you're right
you're right you're right that's right
he just ordered one crab cake yeah no
who does that no so here's my theory
about the biden presidency it's actually
an episode of the masked singer
um
so so so we don't really know who's
president and i think the person who
should replace joe is the person who's
actually president right now only we
never see him
and i have a theory as to who that is i
think behind the teleprompter there's
another person
giving joe lines making him look bad
actually somebody who hates him and
wants him to fail
and who might that be
rudy giuliani
again well you know what the one thing
about hunter he doesn't need anybody to
give him lines
that's true
that was so predictable i'm even
disgusted with it brooke it is great to
see you i am so happy to be back yes
you're a red-eye alumnus oh yes and some
now your need is real
indeed yes that is a country it is you
should come visit i shall does that mean
i'm staying at your place you may
enough of this
[Laughter]
he can't be any worse than his dad right
yeah so what do you think what are you
worried about
well you know i read an article the
other day by douglas murray who was
saying that we need to show compassion
for hunter biden and you know i was
buying it a little bit he's you know the
only surviving son of the president his
his mother and sister perished in a
terrible car accident his brother died
of cancer so he should be in
self-imposed exile dealing with his
issues but instead he is literally front
and center
at the white house he's serving on
boards he's throwing himself out there
as a public figure and it's a national
security issue so i really do think we
should be paying attention to this i
don't think it's a joke i think it's
super scary and the other thing i find
very troubling there was a poll that was
just released
64
of democrats
don't want biden to be the president
okay but they just say hunter no they
didn't okay they don't want the
president they want the president to
step down and to be replaced by another
uh a democrat and that is a vote of no
confidence by your own
party yeah that's kind of scary i think
that's unprecedented yeah i think it's
he has like some like the worst numbers
in history since we had first had
presidents in the 1950s after having
gotten the most votes yes
in history
[Applause]
what do you think tyrus another
brilliant idea out of this fertile brain
that that is
lodged walter i love the 3 a.m joke
[Laughter]
absolutely riveting uh i only imagine
the size of laughter if it would have
came from your
mouth greg said half the audience won't
get it and i said yeah but the best half
will yes
and that's the guy you cheer for there
you go um
i respectfully disagree with you uh
i think hunter had a responsibility
for his past brothers and sisters to be
the best
that he could be but unfortunately
and mr kern talked about this he had a
horrible role model as a father who
again i've said it a million times bad
parenting enabling constantly throwing
money instead of time
public service how can you serve the
public when you can't serve your home i
don't understand that i don't get that
and we're seeing it in grand fashion
it's all coming to roost you mr and i
again you weren't around so you can't
steal any of this
we talked
about
this is bad parenting enabling on the
grand scale american homes across the
country deal with this and most good
parents they cut them off and they deal
with it and he never did that and now
you want to know who hunter's looking at
in all the videos he's looking at dad
he's and he's fearless because he knows
no matter what he does dear old dad and
our tax paying money and our secret
service are gonna make it all go away
and now it's not and
he doesn't care because he stopped
caring a long time ago anyone who does
this stuff to himself doesn't care
by the way i like it when you call me
mister
yeah well that's because that's because
you're a racist no it's because he was
well raised
that was payback
that was payback you know what
you can boo him
[Laughter]
hey
and by the way
we know right now that white men cannot
be racist it's outsourced to us
we did replace you
[Laughter]
cat you know um i'm gonna go back and a
full-throated no pun intended defense of
hunter he has he lacks he lacks the
possib any potential for shame doesn't
that make you a great leader not to be
embarrassed
yeah yeah
and
so i get that your monologue you're kind
of like joking i'm not
i get it that you're kind of joking and
you're committing to the bit right now
and that's great
um why is everybody being so mean to me
but what did i do
maybe it was a feminist award
yeah yourself
so
but
what's not funny is that if given the
choice between him and his dad he
actually is more qualified to be the
president
[Laughter]
even with all of the crack and the
hookers and everything else
he
he's he always remembers to film yes
and and there so many democrats are
still acting like of course but you know
biden's running it's like bro running
where
i like i it seems like it feels like
gaslighting at this point when they act
that way like of course why would you
say that two reasons i can see i can
hear
like
if i was shaking hands with the air i
wouldn't be able to come back to work
the next day
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else